please haha that's cool freeze yeah but
this is the best part the way rich is
gonna do it right here is the way you
should do it to get control over any
clue through the technique shown very
soon here I'm going to instruct rich
into a breathing techniques which has
shown itself to be so effective their
people injected with the endotoxin
that's a e.coli bacteria within a
quarter of hour
they had no headaches no uncontrolled
shivering no agony no pain no fever and
that's what this breathing exercise is
doing it swim hundred meters on the idea
is that chronic mom never is in your
short hang by one finger up in the air
over one half kilometer okay I can do
that I can do that I can do it because
the cold water taught me to go into the
deepest of my mind which is deep emotion
which is my heart that heart right now
brings solutions to those who live in
despair who live in despair depression
who live in inflammation and have no
control I tell you the control is there
lying relax and then you got a ballet
chest and your head so I ask you fully
in Bali just hat letting go and now
fully and again letting go
luli Oh luli letting go letting go like
the waves in the sea they come up on the
shore and letting go make intensify
bring your focus to the flow to these
symptoms lightheadedness loosen the body
and it becomes stronger your body
becomes charged charged with oxygen all
the way past the lymphatic nuts into the
depth of the lymphatic system making it
alkaline it's happening carbon dioxide
is gonna go out but it's becoming
alkaline lightheadedness is all good
okay calm down from 1550 boolean it's a
great workout this exercises the
vascular system more than running so it
is a real workout relax
not being in the mind adjusting your
body the body is doing its work it knows
the Vedas is knowing when you feel the
urge to breathe boolean and halt
35 times calm down no thinking just
doing no thinking do it oh let it go if
you do this this week correctly you are
able to tackle your inflammation like
flus and colds and anything that has to
relay or is related with inflammation
you are the master over your own
chemistry
you are the alchemist as simple as it is
well doctor thank you that was amazing
great going exemplifying for the rest of
the world amazing I feel great I feel
very still and clear and relaxed it's
different from polar tropic breathing
which is much more aggressive and then
you get the techne in their hands so I
didn't quite have that I was sort of
bordering on I could feel that would
have calm if I'd kept going but it's a
more gentle approach
it's what yoga is driving at all the
postures and the poses and the physical
aspect of yoga is really just to calm
and prepare the mind for the shavasana
that follows so it feels like the way
that you feel in the latter phases of a
great meditation but with a calmness of
the body mmm companies because normally
breathing and oxygen is related to
sympathetic nervous system activities we
are with that brain activating that part
the cortisol and all now we break it we
don't breathe thus the cycle is being
broken and you fall into the
parasympathetic activity breath is life
and call this God rat is live and gold
is cut
yeah yeah I can tell yeah yeah it is so
they taught me better than any book
better than anybody else for those who
need we are there and we did it and we
did it we did it we're bloody dead yes
so if you guys want to learn more about
wim the wim HOF method
this guy's universe listen to our
podcast watching on YouTube and links
are below - all the pertinent
information about how you can attend one
of his workshops and experience what I
just experienced modern-day spiritual
warrior right here this this guy
Emma it is likewise due respect this era
this is respect here here we stand up
yeah we are the Warriors
you